بالمناسبة ، ظهرت الرسائل اليوم
من إيران من الممثلين الرسميين هناك
قرروا الاعتراف بأنهم قدموا طائرات بدون طيار
من أجل الإرهاب الروسي ولكن هذا أيضًا كل شيء
من المسلم به أنهم كذبوا علينا بشأن الله
إسقاط ما لا يقل عن 10 طائرات إيرانية بدون طيار
قطع والنظام الإيراني يدعي ذلك
يزعم أنه أعطى القليل حتى قبل البداية
غزو ​​شامل فقط
خلال يوم واحد أمس كان
تم تدمير 11 شهيد ونحن نعرف بالضبط ماذا
مدرسون إيرانيون يقومون بتدريس اللغة الروسية
الإرهابيين لاستخدام الطائرات بدون طيار و v
الإيرانيون صامتون بشكل عام بشأن هذا وما إذا كان
كنت في وقت مبكر سوف تستمر في الكذب
من الواضح أن هذا يعني أن العالم
سوف تبذل المزيد من الجهود ل
التحقيق في التعاون الإرهابي
الأنظمة الروسية والإيرانية وذاك
ما الذي تدفعه روسيا مقدمًا مقابل مثل هذا الشيء
شراكة